alright Pat it is time for caffeine a
david pakman show coffee is now
available we have 2 roasts this is just
fantastic the labels were which you see
here if you're watching the labels were
created by david pakman show viewer
Madeline quirk we have a local coffee
roaster called blue fire coffee roasters
I actually showed up there and we
roasted the coffee together so we could
pick exactly what it is that we're going
to be offering and now at david
pakman.com slash gear or you can go to
david pakman.com and click on shop at
the top of the page you can order either
or both coffees we have a drip coffee
blend good for percolators chemex french
press etc called freedom of the press
that's that's one option and we have
this my preference because I'm more of
an espresso guy although Pat told me a
crazy story the other day about how he
doesn't really drink espresso based
coffee but we'll deal with that a little
bit later called progressive wake-up
call and that is our espresso blend both
are now available at david pakman.com
slash gear and we have I have an order
of each coming in today because I'm
going to be doing some coffee related
videos actually making the coffee and
orders have already started coming in as
of last night this is we it's finally
happening I was going to say I mean we
should have a segment on the show where
we just test these different blends of
coffee absolutely yeah oh there's no
doubt about it you can also get these in
whole bean or whatever grind coarseness
you want for the application you'll be
using you can select it when you order
and it's very exciting now do you want
to address the espresso Pat controversy
now you let me don't let me speculate I
don't remember what you're talking about
and you said you don't really drink
espresso based drinks that you just
drink drip coffee yeah but I don't know
if there's much of a story there that's
huge okay that's a huge story and I
believe it relates to veganism because
other than an Americano or just a
straight espresso with no dollop of foam
on it most espresso-based drinks are not
vegan got you I didn't even think of
that angle but I always just preferred
black coffee anyway I think any kind of
cream any kind of sugar yeah
ruins the taste for me Wow well I
predict needs based on Pat's Pat's
coffee views ok so anyway will will you
know deal with what's going on with Pat
and coffee a little bit later I don't
have that much time for it today but
david pakman.com slash gear is the place
get freedom of the press you can get the
progressive wake-up call it's all
happening and i am actually going to be
visiting blue fire coffee roasters soon
and we'll do a video of me maybe putting
on the full suit that is necessary to
actually you don't you can just you can
basically roast coffee in normal clothes
but just for make it funnier I might
wear something like a beekeepers outfit
when roasting the coffee because I think
visually it'll be funnier you're going
to have to get a shot of that for
Instagram